lorsqu'un requin dax à mâchoires
inférieure et projeter en avant
de sorte que les premières rangées de
dents entre en contact avec la proie
les dons inférieurs ont une forme
appropriée pour retenir la victime puis
la mâchoire supérieure sa baisse et mais
en fonction les dents destinée à couper
les dents de la mer le best-seller de
peter bentley que l'adaptation
cinématographique de steven spielberg a
transformé en un phénomène mondial
l'histoire publiée en 1974 se base sur
des faits réels dans les années 60 les
observations de requin était devenue
fréquente sur les côtes américaines et
la presse ne lésinait pas sur les
nouvelles qui étaient souvent exagérées
au point d'instaurer un véritable climat
de peur lorsqu'un requin et choix
injures sur une plage pour cette foule
de beignes rebaï ce fut une occasion
unique pour voir de près le terrible
monstre
dans l'imagination collective le danger
s'identifier dans le formidable requin
blanc définit comme le plus intelligent
et le plus cruel de tous les animaux
marins
au cours des 100 dernières années les
requins ont attaqué environ 600 fois
l'homme faisant une centaine de morts
dans la plus grande partie des cas le
requin n'avait pas du tout l'intention
d'attaquer l'homme mais il avait tout
simplement pris une planche de surf pour
un phoque qui est sa proie préférée
le requin est ainsi devenu le cauchemar
de tous ceux qui aiment nager au loin ou
chevaucher les ondes des grand'mères
mais comment devons nous comporter pour
nous sentiers plus sûr et éviter d'être
attaqué par le prédateur des mers
il y avait quelque chose d'inquiétant
dans l'air ce matin là le ciel des
nuages gris une petite pluie fine
tombait david roche et brillant taux qui
sont d'excellents amis l'amitié qui les
unit est alimenté par une passion
commune la pêche sous marine
en 1963 il participe au championnat
annuel qui se déroule sur les côtes
australiennes
brian m'a dit d'après moi il ya quelque
chose là bas mais moi je ne voyais rien
brian se trouve à moins de 30 mètres de
la plage alors qu'il s'apprête à sortir
de l'eau il est attaqué par un requin
brian perd son fusil et son masque et il
est entraîné par les tourbillons produit
par la violence de l'agresseur
le requin leur tient entre ses mâchoires
brian cherche en vain de se libérer de
cette prise terrible et de retourner à
la surface dans ce document dramatique
tourner immédiatement après la
récupération du corps de brian il est
possible de voir les lacérations
produite par l' attaque mortelle de
requin
il est rare que le requin déchiquette ou
dévore l'homme mais dans les rares cas
d' attaque les blessures causées par les
terribles dans peuvent provoquer de
graves hémorragies et entraîné la mort
après avoir attaqué brian le requin
agressent david
j'ai juste eu le temps d'apercevoir la
silhouette du requin j'ai d'abord vu
l'aileron dorsal qui se rapprochait le
museau les yeux les dents il m'a attrapé
le pied droit avec une rapidité
surprenante c'est peut-être parce que
j'essayais de lui décroché un coup de
pied je ne pouvais rien faire d'autre
j'ai réussi à extraire manqué de la
bouche du requin mais il m'a attaqué à
nouveau david essaient de résister à
l'attack il réussit enfin à se libérer
et à rejoindre la rive
tout ce dont je me souviens c'est que
j'ai entendu des hurlements
les gens criaient à requins arquin
sortait de l'eau les deux pieds de david
sont blessés les dents du requin ont
provoqué une fracture au pied gauche et
ouvert une entaille profonde
david est hospitalisé pendant deux
semaines
70 points ont été nécessaires pour
suturer ses blessures pour bayonne
malheureusement il n'y a plus rien à
faire
il a perdu trop de sang
les mers du monde entier compte plus de
350 espèces de requins parmi ces espèces
cinq seulement sont considérés comme
potentiellement dangereuse pour l'homme
l'histoire de l'évolution des poissons
cartilagineux qui comprennent requins et
raies a commencé il ya 400 millions
d'années
parmi les requins qui peuplent les
maires australienne celui qui attaque le
plus facilement l'homme et le quart
charaudeau car charia le grand requin
blanc
il peut atteindre sept mètres de long et
peser deux tomes il se nourrit
principalement de mammifères marins tels
que fox lion marin et dauphin
quelquefois le requin blanc ne dédaigne
pas les croyants une taille plus grande
que de coutume comme l'homme toutefois
la prédation sur l'homme n'est pas un
événement fréquent
alors pourquoi une telle panique dès
qu'un requin mort une planche de surf ou
simplement lorsque la silhouette d'un
poisson apparaît à l'horizon
nous avons tous peur des requins parce
que nous craignons surtout d'être dévoré
vivant mais en réalité il est très rare
qu'un homme soit dévoré par un requin
dans la plupart des cas ils se limitent
à mordre la victime plus il s'éloigne on
ne connaît que quelques cas d' attaques
de la part des requins qui ont conduit à
la mort mais il s'agit vraiment de
quatre airs un peu d'animaux possède une
gamme de mécanismes sensorielle aussi
sophistiqués que les requins les requins
peuvent sentir leur proie à des
kilomètres grâce à une wii
particulièrement sensibles aux sons à
basses fréquences comme celles qui sont
émises dans la nature par un poisson
blessés ou par des mouvements
désordonnés les requins peuvent sentir
l'odeur de la proie à plusieurs
centaines de mètres
grâce à une odeur a particulièrement
développée dans le cerveau des requins
les la baule factices sont très
développés
l'eau entre par les marines et parcourt
un chemin obligatoire en passant par des
cellules spéciales qui analyse la
présence de substances odorantes
les requins peuvent reconnaître la
présence de substances alimentaires
même si elles sont très diluées comme un
g de poissons dans une tonne d'eau grâce
à une série de petits canaux situé le
long de la ligne latérale et contenant
des cellules sensorielles
ils peuvent percevoir le moindre
mouvement effectué dans un rayon de 100
mètres
enfin le museau des requins est tapissé
de minuscules ports qui sont les
ouvertures des ampoules de lorenzini et
qui leur permettent de reconnaître les
champs électriques
la sensibilité électrique des requins
est la plus intense de tout le règne
animal
leur sens du goût est plutôt développer
car ils ont dans la bouche dans le
pharynx des papilles gustatives
semblable au nôtre lorsque les requins
manger une nourriture au goût
désagréable il l'a recrache en ouvrant
la bouche
et bien qu'il soit désormais certain que
la chair humaine ne fait pas partie de
leur nourriture préférée des études ont
été effectuées en tenant compte des
aliments qui ne me plaisent pas afin de
réaliser un répulsif anti requins utile
aux personnes devant travailler dans des
environnements marins dangereux
la nuit avant que rendez-leur ne soit
attaquée par un requin au large de la
côte de cause de l'eau un gros banc de
poisson avait été signalée de plus un
petit foc avait été aperçu à 10 mètres à
peine de la plage
quiconque se trouvait dans une telle
situation aurait dû quitter rapidement
l'eau il ne faut pas oublier en effet
que les requins se déplace très
rapidement il est également important de
ne pas attirer l'attention du prédateur
en général plus le requin est grand plus
les proies auxquels ils donnent la
chasse sont grandes
un grand requin blanc de 6 mètres sera
donc plus intéressé à un phoque ou un
baleineau carrément de petits poissons
cette colonie de phoques de lyon marins
qui peuplent une île au large de la côte
méridionale de l'australie est l'un des
garde-manger des requins blancs un
requin peut sentir l'odeur d'un phoque à
plusieurs kilomètres de distance
les phoques possède une couche épaisse
de graisse sous cutanée
lorsqu'un requin réussi en attraper un
il peut rester deux semaines sans
nourriture pour pouvoir battre en
vitesse la proie dont il se nourrit le
grand requin blanc chasse en attaquant
par surprise
nager au milieu d'un groupe de phoques
peut être amusant mais aussi extrêmement
dangereux il n'est pas facile de
s'apercevoir de la présence d'un requin
blanc et il ya de fortes probabilités
d'être pris pour un phoque
ceci explique le motif pour lequel le
nombre de surfeurs attaqué par un requin
est aussi élevé les surfeurs doivent
être très alléchant aux yeux d'un requin
pendant qu'ils bougent brasey gens dans
laurent mata lalonde
pour se défendre de l'agression d'un
requin le meilleur moyen est de
l'attaqué
j'ai essayer de l'atteindre aux yeux
parce que je sais que ces comprimés plus
vulnérables le requin s'est éloigné
n'est que je suis remonté sur la planche
de surf
il est retourné à l'attack je vais alors
frapper à nouveau
j'ai senti à l'improviste un coup
violent j'ai vu la planche volée je ne
me souviens plus de rien tout ce dont je
me rappelle c'est que cette forme énorme
mais poussée dans l'eau
l'intérêt pour les habitants de la mer a
captivé le cinéma et la télévision et
nombreuses sont les troupes occupé à
filmer les grands requins
même les riches touristes sont également
prêts à débourser beaucoup d'argent pour
photographier la terreur des mers à
travers une cage de protection spéciale
dans le monde entier cinq cents
personnes environ ont pu librement
observé un requin blanc
c'est une expérience qui ne s'oublie pas
observez un requin qui nagent de
librement est un spectacle unique au
monde en restant dans la cage il est
possible de profiter du spectacle sans
aucune crainte le requin glisse dans
l'eau et nagent dans le milieu aquatique
avec un mouvement sinueux et à une
vitesse impressionnante
touristes et opérateur de cinéma ne sont
pas les seuls à s'intéresser aux requins
de nombreux biologistes marins ont
concentré leurs recherches sur ces
poissons cartilagineux dont le squelette
est justement constitué de cartilage et
non pas dos
ils mangent souvent en zigzag
ce qui leur permet de pouvoir flotter
sans s'arrêter et pouvoir repérer la
source d'un bruit
en effet leur cerveau qu'on parle des
informations fournies par la narine
droite avec celles qui sont communiquées
par la narine gauche chez certaines
espèces comme les requins marteaux cette
nage très sinueuse est particulièrement
évidente car les narines situés aux
extrémités latéral de la tête sont très
distantes l'une de l'autre pour pouvoir
suivre les requins les chercheurs
utilisent un véhicule sous-marin
spéciale la technologie moderne a permis
d'observer pour la première fois un
requin dans son habitat naturel en
pleine mer
où
ap
grâce aux recherches sur les requins il
a été possible d'obtenir de nombreuses
informations sur leurs techniques de
chasse et sur les systèmes que ces
poissons utilisent pour se camoufler la
partie inférieure de leur corps est
clair pour pouvoir mieux se confondent
avec la surface lumineuses de l'eau la
partie supérieure à une couleur foncée
et se superposent à l'obscurité des
profondeurs réussir à bien se camoufler
est aussi important pour les prédateurs
que pour les proies
même si elles fonctionnent comme des
armes très dangereuses et cruellement
efficace les dents des requins ne sont
pas plantés dans les alvéoles avec les
racines comme les nôtres mais elles sont
simplement fixé dans les gencives ce qui
les rend particulièrement instable ceci
explique pourquoi les mâchoires ont
plusieurs rangées de dents
seules les premières rangées sont
fonctionnels tandis que les autres sont
de réserve un seul exemplaire peut
changer au cours de son existence
trente mille ans environ
ce qui semble être un gros caillot de
sang dans l'eau est en réalité le krill
un amas d'animaux très petits qui
remonte des profondeurs marines les
requins sont en mesure de voir le krill
et dans la vallée de grandes quantités
en une seule bouchée
pour eux c'est aussi facile que de
prendre une poignée de pop corn
lorsqu'on parle de requins l'esprit
évoque immédiatement des images de peur
et de férocité alors que dans la réalité
de nombreuses espèces de requins sont
tout à fait inoffensive
le requin le plus grand qui est aussi le
plus grand de tous les poissons et le
requin baleine qui mesure 20 mètres et
pèse environ 20000 kg
ce n'est pas un chasseur féroce ils
nagent lentement en tenant la bouche
ouverte qui peut avoir une ampleur de
deux mètres mais il ne se nourrit que de
plancton et de petits poissons
il est pratiquement inoffensif pour
l'homme
le requin taupe bleu au corps faim et à
la tête pointu est un chasseur rapides
et agressifs
il se nourrit de poissons de surface
comme le ton et le maquereau
oh
le requin pèlerin mesure 11 mètres il
pèse 4 tonnes et ne mangent que de tous
petits animaux qu'ils pêchent dans la
masse flottante de plancton le requin
pèlerin se comporte comme un filtre
gigantesque
sa bouche est une sorte de grand devin
d'aspiration
le poisson marteau est certainement l'un
des membres les plus curieux est
extravagant du groupe des requins on ne
connaît pas encore le motif de la forme
curieuse de sa tête qui s'élargit
quelquefois jusqu'à 80 cm probablement
les lobes latéraux avec les yeux situés
aux extrémités des deux protubérances
ont la fonction de stabilisateur d'
équilibre
le requin nourrice habitent les fonds
marins ses dents sont nombreuses et a
filé parfaite pour rompre la carapace
des crustacés on pense que les longues
moustaches sensibles situés sur sa tête
aplatie l'aide à identifier ses proies
caché sur le fond il passe une grande
partie de son temps
il faudrait démentir une autre légende
qui concerne ma force constructive d'un
requin même du plus féroce sa force est
très grande mais pas comme on pourrait
l'imaginer
en effet les mesures effectuées avec un
instrument spéciale appelée nyatto
dynamomètre ont démontré que cette force
est égale à celle de l'homme si ce n'est
inférieur
nous avons pu constater que certaines
légendes sur les requins ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
mais cela n'empêche pas d'associer la
bouche d'un requin à la sensation de
terreur
il existe pourtant d'autres poissons
féroce et au caractère agressif qui
bénéficie d'une sympathie imméritée de
la part de l'homme
en voici quelques-uns
les réels sont des créatures marines à
la forme plate étrange élégantes elles
ont d'énormes nageoires semblables à des
ailes et une queue fine et pointue on ne
connaît plus de 350 espèces
ce sont des animaux dont la structure
osseuse est remplacé par un tissu
cartilagineux ne possédant pas de vessie
natatoire elles doivent pour ne pas
couler nager sans s'arrêter et en
déplaçant leurs nageoires qui ressemble
à des ailes elle semble presque volé
dans l'eau
à cause de leur aspect peu
hydrodynamique il est difficile de les
voir nager
elle passe donc la plupart de leur temps
sur les fonds marins et leur corps plats
les rend difficilement repérable
lorsqu'elles sont immobiles et
recouverte de sable
en attendant patiemment leurs proies
tandis qu'elle gisait sur le fond de
petits orifices situé derrière les yeux
font office des vents pour leur
permettre de respirer
les poissons rapide échappent à leurs
attaques et le régime des raies se
limite donc principalement aux poissons
blancs ou blessés aux mollusques
crustacés et autres créatures qu'elle
trouve sur le fond de la mer
la bouche de l'arrêt est doté de dents
robuste capable de broyer les coquilles
des coquillages des plus coriaces leur
corps plats et recouvert de minuscules
écailles et leurs longues que porte un
aiguillon dans play et venimeux qui peut
devenir une arme plutôt efficace
oh
avec d'énormes nageoires pectorales en
pointe l'amendé la plus grande des raies
elle peut atteindre 4 mètres de long et
7 mètres de large
sa tête cadre angulaire est muni de deux
petites nageoires tourné vers l'avant
extrêmement mobile et sensible elle est
complètement désarmé elle ne possède ni
d'en nier guillon qu'au dos et n'a que
son grand gabarit et elle est capable de
nager à plus de 25 kilomètres heure la
raie manta se nourrit principalement de
plancton de crustacés et de poissons de
petite taille qu'un capture tout
simplement nageant la bouche grande
ouverte
elle est assez docile mais son aspect
imposant et ses deux nageoires
céphalique lui ont donné le surnom de ré
diable
dans les superstitions des indigènes
polynésiens la raie manta est considéré
comme un monstre capable de capturer
l'homme dans une étreinte mortelle en
enveloppant dans ces énormes zèle et en
l'entraînant dans les ténèbres des fonds
marins pour le transformer en diable ce
fut un prétexte pour les exterminer
aujourd'hui les rites propitiatoires
semble être devenu plus efficace pour se
défendre du diable de la mer
les méduses peuple depuis très longtemps
nous mère elle était bien connu de nos
ancêtres
aristote et planus décrivent en détail
les terribles supplications provoqué par
leurs tentacules que la mythologie
grecque associe à la chevelure de
serpent de cet être effrayant ap les
méduses dont le regard pétrifié
quiconque le croiser
la distribution géographique de ces
animaux transparent et gélatineux
capable d'assumer des teintes colorées
luminescents est tellement vaste qu'on
les trouve sur toutes les latitudes
environ 4000 espèces de méduses sont
connus grandes et petites situées en bas
de la classification aux logiques tout
de suite après l'eponge ce sont des
animaux planctoniques c'est à dire
qu'ils font partie du plancton et
appartiennent au groupe des cnidaires
animaux aquatiques qui se nourrissent de
proies capturé au moyen de capsules
urticantes doté de crochets qui en
s'accrochant à la peau de leurs proies
ou de leurs ennemis inocule une
substance paralysante
la plus grande partie des méduses
préfère nager dans les zones littorales
dans un milieu aquatique plus
superficielle où elle se maintienne en
équilibre grâce à leur densité voisine à
celle de l'eau
bien que constitué d'une masse
gélatineuse elle possède des muscles
circulaire qui transmettent à leur corps
une contraction rythmique la pulsation
continue permet également à l'animal de
se déplacer lentement mais en cas de
nécessité une contraction brusque
projettent un jet d'eau qui fonctionne
comme un propulseur et lui permet de se
déplacer très rapidement
pour s'arrêter elle reprend sa forme de
parapluie ouvert et ses tentacules se
détendent
lorsque la méduse ouvre ses tentacules
elle devient extrêmement dangereuse elle
consomme ses proies vivantes surtout les
petits crustacés et n'hésite pas à
avaler tout ce qu'elle trouve provoquant
le massacre d'alevins ont chois sardines
maquereaux et quelquefois même d'autres
méduses
son appareil digestif contient des
enzymes poteo lithiques très puissante
en mesure d'attaquer les protéines des
animaux pour augmenter la capacité
d'absorption et la méduse a déjà digéré
la tête d'un poisson alors que la queue
s'agit encore hors de sa bouche
la durée de vie des méduses et de deux
mois à un an et leur taille varie selon
les espèces le diamètre du para pipe
quelquefois atteindre la dimension
exceptionnelle de 3 mètres et les
tentacules redoutable 50 m
la méduse de la légende terrorisait les
anciens et aujourd'hui encore la méduse
qui peuplent les eaux de la côte est
plutôt crainte son venin est en mesure
de paralyser en quelques minutes un
homme et de le conduire à la mort
paradoxalement ces animaux ont toutefois
contribué à d'importantes découvertes
pour l'humanité
grâce à des études approfondies certains
physiologiste français en analysant la
nature du venin des méduses ont
découvert le mécanisme qui entraîne le
choc anaphylactique ouvrant ainsi une
voie permettant d'expliquer le phénomène
très complexe des allergies
de plus les méduses ont également fourni
des informations utiles sur la
transmission des impulsions nerveuses en
absence de gravité durant leur vol
interplanétaire abords du chanteur en
juin 1991
dans l'obscurité de la nuit d'étranges
lueurs brille dans les ténèbres des
fonds marins c'est le plancton existence
fondamental de toute la chaîne
alimentaire des océans au printemps
durant les nuits de pleine lune
les calmars sont attirés la surface par
cette abondance de nourriture dans les
eaux profondes et obscur des canyons
marins ces céphalopodes pendant la
période de reproduction se regroupent en
grand nombre
il n'est pas rare que durant la coupe le
mans il utilise le tentacule car les
mains sont capables de se battre
sauvagement pour la conquête des
femelles
après c'est un couple et beaucoup
d'entre eux meurent naturellement s'ils
n'ont pas été les victimes de leurs
nombreux prédateurs les plus voraces et
en l'airé pastenagues qui volent parmi
les bancs de calamar ailé dévore
parmi toutes les créatures vivant dans
la mer les céphalopodes sont les plus
nombreux et représentent une partie
vitale de la chaîne alimentaire de
l'océan
ce sont justement les calmars qui
approvisionne une grande partie de
l'industrie de la pêche
chaque année surtout au japon et au
moyen-orient on en consomme environ 2
millions de tonnes
de récentes documentation parle de
calmars géants et on a même retrouvé sur
la plage les cadavres de ces étranges
créatures appelées architetti ce qui
signifie en grec à la marque
préhistorique
le géant de la mer est un formidable
prédateur et peut atteindre une longueur
considérable de 20 mètres tentacules
compris et peser une tonne
face à lui toutes formes de vie marine
semble insignifiante
ils habitent les eaux profondes et c'est
un carnivore impitoyable qui
s'aventurent la nuit à la surface pour
chercher de la nourriture
il possède des armes mortelles une masse
longue agile de tentacules recouvert de
ventouses ou de crochets semblable à
dessert ses tentacules qui entoure la
tête sont capables de prendre au piège
la proie dans un enchevêtrement mortels
puis de la broyé avec une bouche qui
ressemble à un bec de perroquet ses yeux
sont énormes et menaçant les plus grands
du royaume animal
malgré de récentes recherches
l'atmosphère de terreur qui flotte
autour de ces monstres n'a jamais
disparu
le journal de bord du capitaine d'un
navire de guerre français raconte qu'un
monstre marin a attaqué son embarcation
cet épisode enflamment l'imagination de
l'écrivain jules verne qui publiera en
1870 son célèbre vin milieu sous les
mers et où le capitaine nemo défend
courageusement le nautilus contre
l'attack de l'architecte is le calmar
géant
quoi qu'il en soit le requin reste le
dominateur incontesté du continent sous
marins il inspire crainte et respect à
tous ceux qui vivent dans les océans
mais aussi à ceux qui travaillent sur
les océans
dans le sud du continent africain autour
de l'île de madagascar
vive les baisses dernières populations
nomades de l'océan indien
les vestes sont spécialisés dans la
pêche aux requins une pêche pour de
l'argent et leur bulletin est vendu aux
commerçants puis réapprovisionnent la
cuisine asiatique ou le requin est très
apprécié dans le passé les baisses
étaient très superstitieux et pensait
que l'animal avait une âme
les anciens racontaient que tuer un
requin pouvait bouleverser l'ordre des
choses et c'est ainsi qu'une légende
pris vie un jour un pêcheur remontant
son fils dans le parc découvrit bête
horrible après avoir surmonté sa peur il
s'approcha de l'animal et lui dit je te
demande pardon je ne voulais pas attaqué
nous sommes tous deux fils de la mer et
je me considère donc comme ton frère je
ne veux pas te tuer il coupa le filet et
laissa le requin libres de s'en aller
qui dès ce jour commencé à pousser de
grands bancs de poissons vers les filets
du pêcheur
aujourd'hui en mémoire des légendes de
leurs ancêtres les baisses respecte que
le requin sa pêche est devenue une
activité de prestige et à renforcer le
sens de noyauter dans la compétition
entre l'homme et l'animal
à des milliers de kilomètres de là de
l'autre côté de l'océan indien dans la
mer qui sépare les îles indonésiennes de
java et sumatra
c'est une excellente journée pour les
pêcheurs la proie est énorme
c'est un requin tigre l'une des espèces
les plus faire ce qui peuplent la mer il
mesure 4 mètres et il sait voracement
jeter sur l'apa
le requin est encore vivant et les
hommes lutte durement pour le hisser à
bord de la barque
il tire de toutes leurs forces mais les
500 kg de l'animal pourrait faire
renverser le bateau sans penser que
d'autres requins pourraient être attirés
par l'odeur du sang le plus courageux
des pêcheurs plonge pour attacher
l'extrémité d'une corde à la queue du
requin
la lutte quotidienne avec la mer et ses
fruits et très dure et dangereuse mais
elle le luron avec un bien-être et une
sécurité sociale décente
le requin est une des proies les plus
rémunératrices en effet à ces latitudes
ses ailerons sont un plat très
recherchés mais contrairement à leurs
collègues de hong kong est du japon
cette partie du requin n'est pas la
seule qui intéresse ces pêcheurs
carrément
petit
le défi avec le prédateur des mers fait
également partie de la magie et d'un
rituel qui les porte à le respecter à le
craindre
le battre est plus important que le fait
d'avoir pêché un gros poisson pour cette
raison également la chair du requin qui
n'est pas particulièrement gouttes et
finit par devenir un plaisir recherché
et coûteux
une famille de lamentin cet animal est
protégé car il est en voie de
disparition
mais ceci ne l'intéresse pas l'appétit
du requin
lamentin et du gong dévore littéralement
toute la végétation sous marine ces
excellents nageurs sont difficiles à
rejoindre
le requin tigre appartient lui aussi à
la famille des puissants prédateurs et
il contribue sans le vouloir au maintien
du grand équilibre naturel grâce aux
requins la population des lamantins
conclure à être stable pendant de
nombreuses années encore et la
végétation restera florissant mais
quelle est la présence et le vrai danger
des requins dans les mers italiennes
à l'heure actuelle la présence de
quarante et une espèce de requin a été
signalée avec précision cette liste peut
être préoccupante car en plus de
quelques dizaines d'espèces de requins
tout à fait inoffensif
elle enregistre également la présence
des requins blancs toro mac au top et
tigres considérés potentiellement
dangereux pour l'homme
malgré tout les communications informant
que des requins ont attaqué des êtres
humains sont minimes
on compte deux victimes une en 1962
madrid sur sarah célèbre photographe et
chasseurs sous-marins qui mourut suite à
une attaque de requin dans les autres de
l'asec adéquat brrr donnant sur le
promontoire du tir théo l'autre en 1989
quand luciano costanzo perdit la vie au
large de piombino
en raison des blessures dans le premier
cas et des témoignages des présents dans
le deuxième quart le cours de costanzo
n'a jamais été retrouvé on pense que
l'auteur de ces attaques est un grand
requin blanc
même si dans le cas de sarah il n'est
pas exclu qu'il s'agisse d'un requin tôt
ceci est le témoignage exclusif d'un
plongeur sous-marin attaqué par un
requin ce témoignage est accompagné d'un
film tragique jeune âge et au milieu
d'un groupe de phoques
le requin a dû m'apercevoir pour lui je
n'étais rien d'autre qu'un phoque plus
lent que les autres avec moi ils
pouvaient prendre son temps soudain tous
les phoques ont disparu
j'étais sous l'eau j'ai réussi à
remonter à la surface et j'ai attendu
que l'autre plongeur qui était avec moi
à me rejoigne je lui ai alors dit que
les phoques avait certainement senti
quelque chose et que nous devrions
sortir le plus vite possible de l'eau
alors que j'attendais que mon compagnon
remonte le rcam à attaquer
il monte ensuite raconté que j'avais
lever un bras en l'air
c'est le signal que l'on utilise pour
rappeler le secours quand un plongeur
est en difficulté
j'ai allongé une main vers le genou
gauche et j'ai senti que je n'avais plus
la jambe
j'ai réussi difficilement à rejoindre la
surface
je perdais beaucoup de sang quelqu'un a
arraché la sangle d'un harpon et lacéré
autour du moignon de ma jambe
j'ai entendu quelqu'un qui disait il ne
s'en sortira pas regarde là il est pâle
comme un linge
ce qui m'a le plus contrarié c'est que
je n'ai pas réussi à voir le requin qui
m'a mordu
je n'ai pas réussi à me voir même quand
il m'a attaqué
c'est ça surtout qui m'a choqué c'est un
animal extrêmement rapide
malheureusement la soupe aux ailerons de
requin est un plat toujours plus
demandés et coûteux et de nombreux
pêcheurs orientaux pratique le
soi-disant finning que l'on pourrait
traduire par élevage et qui consiste à
couper les nageoires des requins et à
jeter le reste de l'animal par dessus
bord
on
cela leur permet de ne pas remplir les
cales de carcasses de requins dont la
chair n'est pas prise et est de garder
plus de place pour les poissons coûteux
comme par exemple les tons
malgré les attaques dont il est
quelquefois l'auteur le requin à
d'autres choses plus importantes à faire
au cours de sa vie que d'agresser les
êtres humains et nous devons éviter de
les supprimer de la terre les éliminer
signifierait en effet détruire un anneau
fondamental de la chaîne alimentaire de
l'écosystème marin
nous
on